MORE THAN YOU’VE DONE IN 47
YEARS, JOE.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
THE VERY FIRST PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE IS NOW OFFICIALLY IN THE
BOOKS IN THE EXTREMELY WEAK, THE
FRAIL, THE CONFUSED KIND OF
ANGRY JOE BIDEN JUST GOT
STEAMROLLED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JOE FLAT OUT REFUSED TO ANSWER
SIMPLE, BASIC, FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS, UNABLE TO RESPOND TO
THE PRESIDENT’S BEAT DOWNS AND
HE APPEARED FLUSTERED,
IRRITATED, AND WELL, CRANKY.
JOEL, MAYBE IT’S PAST HIS
BEDTIME, PROBABLY STAYED UP TOO
LATE, NEEDS HIS NAP.
WE HAVE A LOT OF LIFE REACTION
FOR THE FULL HOUR, ANALYSIS
MOMENTS AWAY.
DONALD TRUMP JR. WILL BE HERE,
SARAH SANDERS, DAN BONGINO,
JUDGE JEANINE WILL ALSO JOIN US,
ARI FLEISCHER WILL JOIN US AS
WELL, BUT FIRST, LET’S START
WITH JOE BIDEN, WHO ONCE AGAIN
REFUSED TO ANSWER A SIMPLE,
BASIC, FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
WOULD HE SUPPORT PACKING THE
SUPREME COURT?
HE REFUSES TO ANSWER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TONIGHT WHETHER
OR NOT YOU WILL SUPPORT EITHER
ENDING THE FILIBUSTER OR PACKING
THE COURT?
>> WHATEVER POSITION I TAKEN
THAT, THAT WILL BECOME THE
ISSUE.
THE ISSUE IS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SHOULD SPEAK.
YOU SHOULD GO OUT AND VOTE.
YOU ARE IN VOTING NOW, VOTE AND
LET YOUR SENATORS KNOW HOW YOU
FEEL.
VOTE NOW.
MAKE SURE YOU IN FACT LET PEOPLE
KNOW, YOUR SENATORS.
I’M NOT GOING TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION BECAUSE THE QUESTION
IS -- THE QUESTION IS -- THE
QUESTION --
WOULD YOU SHUT UP, MAN?
>> WHO WAS ON YOUR LIST, JOE?
>> GENTLEMEN, I THINK WITH END
OF THIS --
WE HAVE ENDED THIS SEGMENT, WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ONTO THE
SECOND SEGMENT.
>> THAT WAS A REALLY PRODUCTIVE
SEGMENT, WASN’T IT?
>> SHUT UP, JOE.
HE’S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT ALSO.
JOE WON’T ANSWER A PIVOTAL,
IMPORTANT QUESTION ON WHETHER OR
NOT HE PLANNED TO DESTROY THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT WITH A
PRACTICE KNOWN AS COURT PACKING,
PRETTY MUCH A PATHETIC, SIMPLE
QUESTION, WHY COULDN’T HE
ANSWER?
TONIGHT JOE WASN’T JUST REFUSING
TO ANSWER BASIC CIVIL QUESTIONS,
AT TIMES HE COULD BARELY FORM A
SENTENCE.
MANY STRUGGLING MOMENTS, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> 20 -- 200 MILLION -- THE
200,000 PEOPLE THAT HAVE DIED ON
HIS WATCH, HOW MANY OF THOSE
HAVE SURVIVED?
THERE ARE 7 MILLION PEOPLE THAT
HAVE PROTRACTED CONTRACTED COVID
HE PUTS PRESSURE AND DISAGREES
WITH HIS OWN SCIENTISTS.
>> SENATOR HARRIS IS SAYING YOU
CAN’T TRUST THE SCIENCE.
>> YOU CAN TRUST THE SCIENTISTS.
SHE DIDN’T SAY THAT.
>> SHE’S OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS "WILL BE MUZZLED, WILL
BE SUPPRESSED."
>> THAT’S WHAT IS GOING TO TRY
TO DO.
>> THE WAY TO OPEN BUSINESSES IS
TO GIVE THEM THE WHEREWITHAL TO
BE ABLE TO OPEN.
WE PROVIDED MONEY --
>> I WAS ASKING ABOUT MASKS.
>> MASKS MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
BILLIONAIRES HAVE MADE OVER
$300 BILLION BECAUSE OF THE TAX
PROPOSAL AND HE WILL ONLY FOCUS
ON THE MARKET.
YOU HAVE 19 -- 91 COMPANIES
FEDERAL -- IN THE FORTUNE 500
WHO DON’T PAY A SINGLE PENNY AND
TAX.
>> GO AHEAD -- YOU GET THE FINAL
WORD.
>> IT’S HARD TO GET ANY WORD AND
WITH THIS CLOWN -- EXCUSE ME,
THIS PERSON.
>> Sean: IT’S A WONDER THAT
JOE DID SO LITTLE TO IMPROVE THE
COUNTRY.
HE SPENT NEARLY FIVE DECADES IN
THE SWAMP, THE SEWER THAT WE
CALL WASHINGTON, D.C., AS THE
PRESIDENT POINTED OUT, ALSO
NUMEROUS TIMES TONIGHT.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I’VE DONE MORE IN 47
MONTHS -- I’VE DONE MORE THAN
YOU’VE DONE IN 47 YEARS.
WE’VE DONE THINGS THAT YOU NEVER
EVEN THOUGHT OF.
>> Sean: INSTEAD OF ACTUALLY
HELPING AMERICANS, YEP, 47
YEARS, JOE BIDEN WAS BUSY LINING
THE POCKETS OF HIS OWN FAMILY.
IN SPITE OF HIM DENYING IT, HE
IS WRONG.
THAT INCLUDES ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER BIDEN, AND AS WE HAVE
LEARNED THIS WEEK, WE GOT
RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS, WE GOT
UKRAINIAN OLIGARCHS, RUSSIAN
NATIONALS, CHINESE NATIONALS,
UKRAINIAN NATIONALS WHO, YEAH,
ALL IN BUSINESS.
WE HAVE WIRE TRANSFERS, MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FROM UKRAINIAN
RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS, SHOPPING
SPREES COURTESY OF CHINA.
PEOPLE CONNECTED TO THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA AND OF
COURSE THE $1.5 BILLION DEAL
WITH THE BANK OF CHINA.
BUT HE DENIED IT ALL.
NOT TRUE.
>> TRADE DEFICIT WITH MEXICO.
>> NO WONDER, YOUR SON GOES IN
AND HE TAKES OUT -- HE TAKES OUT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, TAKES OUT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, AND ALSO,
WHILE WE ARE AT IT -- JUST OUT
OF CURIOSITY, THE MAYOR OF
MOSCOW’S WIFE GAVE YOUR SON
THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS.
WHAT DID HE DO TO DESERVE IT?
>> Sean: WITH THE MOB, THE
MEDIA, WILL THEY EVER
FACT-CHECKED JOE?
LET’S SEE.
TUESDAY NOVEMBER 3RD, THAT IS 34
DAYS AWAY, SO MUCH IS AT STAKE
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN, CARD CARRYING MEMBER
OF THE SEWER, THE SWAMP, AND HE
HAS BEEN IN WASHINGTON NEARLY 50
YEARS WITH NOTHING TO SHOW FOR
IT BUT A GROWING BANK ACCOUNT
FOR HIS ENTIRE FAMILY.
NOW JOE, HE’S MADE A DEAL WITH
THE RADICAL LEFT AND IN SPITE OF
HIS DENIAL TONIGHT, HE DID GO